gracias por continuar en la pantalla de
france 24 estamos de regreso para
actualizar las principales noticias
económicas de américa latina y del resto
del mundo y por eso nos acompaña por
supuesto jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas
noches bueno comenzamos hablando de la
economía de méxico hay datos no así de
santiago y es que allí la economía se
contrajo levemente en el tercer
trimestre de este año según los datos
del instituto nacional de estadística y
geografía que son el ajuste de los datos
preliminares que mostrarán una
contracción menor del 0,2 por ciento la
economía de méxico se contrajo un 0,4
por ciento en este tercer trimestre
retrocediendo más rápido de lo que se
esperaba entre las causas está la caída
del sector servicios como los problemas
en la cadena de suministro que sumado a
la alta inflación son el principal reto
para el banco central que ahora está
lidiando con el cambio de liderazgo lo
mencionábamos hace unos días por la
nominación de victoria rodríguez ceja
como gobernadora del banco central según
la firma moody's analytics esta
contracción son efectos de un aumento de
las infecciones de kobe 19 en agosto y
una nueva ley de mexico que pretende
eliminar la subcontratación
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
pidió a la población ver con calma los
efectos de esta desaceleración y aseguró
que la economía terminara el año con un
crecimiento del 6% según él por el
aumento del empleo y la inversión
extranjera bueno jorge de mexico
viajamos hasta brasil para hablar de lo
que es la inversión extranjera directa
en el gigante de sudamérica no así que
si es que la cerveza española estrella
galicia anunció la construcción de su
primera fábrica fuera de españa- en el
estado brasileño de sao paulo la
inversión será de 360 millones de
dólares para construir la planta que
será instalada en la ciudad de
araraquara a unos 270 kilómetros de la
capital paulista y debería empezar a
operar a finales de 2023 esta inversión
extranjera en brasil acumulada en los 10
primeros meses del año saltó un 33,3 por
ciento pasó desde los 34 mil 100
millones de dólares entre enero y
octubre de 2020 hasta 45 mil 788
millones de dólares en el mismo período
de este año pero este aumento es
producto de la fuerte caída que sufrió
el flujo de recursos extranjeros el año
pasado como consecuencia la crisis que
provocó la pandemia de kobe 19 y ahora
vamos a eeuu que está celebrando la
tradicional cena de acción de gracias
pero en un contexto económico bastante
complejo verdad así que si según la
asociación de automovilistas de eeuu
48,3 millones de personas recorrerán al
menos 80 kilómetros desde sus casas
durante este festivo un aumento de 4 de
casi 4 millones de personas frente al
año pasado pese al alza de los precios
de la gasolina el de hecho previo a este
festivo los precios de la gasolina
alcanzaron su precio máximo en los
últimos siete años el 17 de noviembre
por ejemplo el precio promedio de un
galón de gasolina en estados unidos era
de 3.41 dólares cuando el año pasado
rondaba los 2,12 por galón pero al oeste
se pagan alguno de los precios más caros
de gasolina en todo eeuu los precios de
la gasolina en california llegaban a 4
dólares con 69 centavos y escuchemos un
poco lo que comentaban por ahí
polvo es horrible quiero decir tienes
que tener un trabajo básicamente solo
para mantenerte conduciendo a tu trabajo
tienes que tener mucho dinero solo para
poner gasolina en tu coche solía llenar
mi tanque de gasolina incluso hace dos
años por unos 50 dólares ahora cuesta
y en realidad voy a quedarme en los
ángeles en lugar de ir a casa por
primera vez para acción de gracias tengo
un billete de avión para navidad pero me
retrasa un poco en la compra del billete
de avión y es bastante caro si lo
compras tarde y con los precios de la
gasolina tan altos voy a tener un
friends que viene en lugar de ir al ver
a mi familia incluso por primera vez
desde que tenía 18 años al 'rating'
santiago y es que la casa blanca
recurrió a las reservas estratégicas de
petróleo en un intento de contrarrestar
la inflación y la escasez previo a este
día de acción de gracia pero varios
analistas afirman que ese alivio es
solamente temporal vamos ahora con
algunos indicadores así de bueno vol 3
estuvo cerrado y por día de acción de
gracias pero en europa las acciones
subieron debido a que los inversores
compraron en sectores defensivos como
los servicios públicos en medio de la
preocupación por el aumento de los casos
de kobe 19 que se contienen y en américa
latina la bolsa de sao paulo subió por
tercera ocasión consecutiva animada por
petrobras y la banca cerramos como
siempre con la cifra del día cuál es hoy
la cifra del 10 14 por ciento eso
aumentó el costo de la cena de acción de
gracias en eeuu la cena para 10 personas
costaría en promedio 53 dólares es decir
unos 530 dólares por persona el año
pasado costaba 46 dólares gracias jorge
por este completísimo repaso por las
principales noticias en materia
económica a nuestra audiencia como
siempre le invitamos a continuar
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france 24 punto com
sigan con nosotros
[Música]